Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god, sorry for being late.
Um, the Minecraft...
The Minecraft, uh, Twitch Rivals lasted longer than I expected.
Um, I thought it'd be three hours, but I guess because we made it to the finals, it was four hours.
Um, but yes, um, spoiler alert, we won.
That's why it took so long.
So, yeah, um, I won't be talking too much about...
There won't be life updates today because, like, today is a special day!
I mean, well, today is a packed day as well, because we also had the Fortnite...
Uh, not the Fortnite, sorry.
We had the Minecraft Twitch Rivals, but today we're also sponsored by Fortnite!
Yes!
This is sponsored by Fortnite!
Well, this video, this stream will be made into a highlight video, which is the official sponsor for it, but, like, since it's coming from this stream, um, uh, we're gonna be checking out the newest updates to Fortnite, so, like, Chapter 6, and some of the newest cosmetics,
the Battle Pass, all of that.
Um, it's actually uh, crazy, uh, because, um, um, I did not expect to get that email.
I was actually not expecting that at all.
I remember when I, I, uh, when I, I, because I read the email first, and I was like, oh my god, is this real?
And then, um, my, uh, my manager that reads the emails was actually on holiday, so then I was like, so I had to reply to myself, to it myself, and I was like, um, hello, this is the Doki Bird team, and, like, I'm so interested.
I was like, hi, this is the Doki Bird team, and, like, we'd like to know more details about this, uh, about the sponsor, uh, that you're, oh shit, Mint!
Oh, I have it disabled?
Wait, I have, no, it's cause Mint's not subscribed to me!
Hahahahaha!
That's right!
Mint, I have it so that you have to be subscribed to me to raid me.
That's...
Hahahahaha!
That's a key, right?
Exposed!
Hahahahaha!
Actually, I don't know if that's true, I just said that just to, like, make you feel a little bad.
Actually, let me, let me check.
Actually, I don't even remember how to change it, cause I don't remember how to...
Hahahahaha!
Actually, let me check that.
You know, that makes sense!
I was like, that makes sense why now, now that I think about it, I was like, oh yeah, that's why I don't get raided.
Cause I, I have it so that people can't even raid me.
Oh, here.
Sorry, I turned it off.
Um...
Sorry.
Wait, no, I do have it!
Yeah, it's cause you weren't subscribed!
Man!
I don't even know she's here.
I do have that permission on!
You have to be subscribed to her!
Okay, now all channels can...
Now all channels can raid me.
Hahahahaha!
That's a key, right?
I bet she's not even here right now.
Hahahahaha!
I bet she's...
Oh, JK.
No, sorry.
Channels I subscribe to can redirect my content.
Oh, it's disabled because my channel subscription is, is private!
Oh!
It's cause, okay, now I understand.
It's cause, it's cause if the channel subscription, if our channel subscriptions are privated, um, so we both have private channel subscription, I'm subscribed!
I know I'm subscribed!
Hahahahaha!
But both of our channel subscriptions are privated, so like, um, you can't see it.
Oh, now you said something, man!
Oh, you were doubting it too!
You were like, wait, am I not actually subscribed?
Hahahahaha!
Okay, now all channels can redirect to my content now.
It's okay.
It's alright, we figured it out.
We figured it out, guys.
So it's both our faults, man.
It's both our faults.
No, I knew I was subscribed!
Hahahahaha!
No, no, it's both our faults, because we both have privated subscriptions, and because we both have privated subscriptions, um, it doesn't just allow redirect...
To redirect...
Hahahahaha!
But now you can read it now!
Yay!
We did it, Mint!
We fixed the problem together!
Look at that!
We fixed the problem together.
Why is Mint not modded?
I don't know.
Why am I not modded on her channel?
I... Hahahahaha!
Hahahahaha!
Um...
Let's see...
But yeah, thank you again for the...
You first.
Um...
Thank you!
I hope everything is okay over there.
Um...
And that you'll feel better watching the stream.
No, her first.
She goes first.
Alright, I'm looking at...
Alright, Mint, I'm gonna look at your channel right now in the chatting thing, and then like, see if I'm modded.
Alright, am I modded?
I'm looking at her upcoming live stream.
Am I modded?
Not modded.
I'm not modded.
Hahahahaha!
Anyway!
As I... As I was saying...
Why you don't... She doesn't even trust me as mod!
She doesn't even trust... This is a give or take, okay guys?
This is a give... A mod... Yeah, you know follow for follow.
Mod for mod.
Anyway, as I was saying, um... Yes, it's actually crazy.
I never expected myself to be uh... to be uh... sponsored by Fortnite of all games, because like, you know, I give them a lot of my money, so like, it's very surprising that they wanna give me money.
But I think they know that I'm gonna use the money they give me to buy more cosmetics and buy more outfits.
So like, to them, they're winning.
Hahahahaha!
Like...
I'm just gonna... I... Okay, so like, yesterday, I played...
If you guys didn't know, I played a little bit of Fortnite on Short4Stream, because he asked me to play Fortnite with him and his friends.
And then, literally, I booted it up, and then I...
I bought so many skins.
I bought so many cosmetics.
I was just like, ooh!
You know you can have Jordans now?
Oh my god, okay, I'm gonna show you guys.
This is actually fucking crazy.
I got... I was...
I was so happy.
Hahahahaha!
Oh, oh yeah!
By the way, I also spent money...
Um... I also...
I spent money... Yes.
Yeah.
Hahahahaha!
I'm Ninja.
Ninja was in the store.
Um...
Hahahahaha!
Ninja was in the store!
I bought the Ninja.
Yeah, look at my sweet Jordans!
Okay, so like...
So you can have shoes now.
You get shoes, and then...
You can't get Godzilla yet, but like...
Okay, but like...
Hahahahaha!
Okay...
But...
Okay, so basically...
Basically...
Frieza can wear...
Um... Frieza can wear Jordans now.
And...
Look at his dress!
Look at it!
I also bought...
I bought the Snoop walk.
I bought a Snoop walk.
Hahahahaha!
Frieza with the Jordans.
Yeah, so like...
Um... I got really excited, and then...
I literally forgot to use my creator code.
Okay, so by the way, guys...
You guys didn't know.
I...
Oh my god, I have Catwoman.
I have a supportive creator code.
So you can use like... You can just put Doki Bird.
And then like, um...
Basically, if you're going to buy skins anyway, I get like a little percentage off of it.
So like, that's basically it.
And then, um...
And...
And this is where my super... No!
John!
No, it goes to other things too!
John, I only use the super chat money from people who like...
Super chat me specifically for Fortnite skins.
Hahahahaha!
And it's a very high percentage.
Um, it doesn't work with my super chat money because this would be the last one.
Your super chat money is diverted to a different cat...
To a different area.
I have people that specifically super chat me just for Fortnite cosmetics and Fortnite outfits.
It's a Fortnite cosmetic fund.
Anyway, so like...
I was so excited.
Yeah, CC!
It's not you, John.
It's not your money.
It's Alan's money.
Super chat to Navel Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So like, basically...
Um, I was so excited that I forgot to use my code.
And I just gave them...
I gave Fortnite like $60 for free.
Oh my god, I...
Look at this.
She's a baddie.
He's a baddie, guys.
Whoa!
He's a fucking baddie.
He's a freaking bad... Okay.
And then...
Stop sharking!
Thank you for the magenta soup fund.
Thank you, thank you.
For the Fortnite cosmetic fund.
50 eagle bills to get more stuff.
Mr. Sand, thank you for the magenta soup fund.
Thank you, thank you.
Brown, thank you for the aqua soup fund.
Super chat for Fortnite cosmetics.
Thank you for the aqua...
See, John?
It's not your fund.
I have enablers.
I have other enablers in my chat.
Maxis, thank you for the...
For the very first super chat to enable me.
Look, ma, I'm an enabler.
See you guys.
Okay, so like...
Oh my god, I have Ariana.
So these are the Jordans.
These are the shoes.
You can get your kicks.
I bought this one because I thought it looked...
Because I'm waiting for Godzilla, basically.
I'm...
Oh my god, did it refresh?
Did it just refresh?
Oh my god, did it... Okay, it's at 4.
Okay, nevermind.
Okay, I was like, what happened?
So I'm waiting for Godzilla.
Godzilla is gonna release in January.
And then when Godzilla releases, I can have...
I can put these shoes on him.
I can put...
That's...
That's why I bought these shoes.
I was like, this is the perfect Godzilla shoes.
Right there.
And then there's like...
Apparently like this...
The theme for chapter 6 is Japan themed.
Because there's a lot of like...
The new map itself has like...
New locations where you're fighting like...
Demons and stuff.
Which looks really cool.
I was playing with Surefour, Gully, and Mr. Cow.
We call him Ben.
And...
Oh yeah, by the way, I finally talked to Moonmoon.
We finally...
You know, like 5 degrees of...
Like 6 degrees of Moonmoon.
Like, now we actually got...
We actually talked to Moonmoon that day.
We actually talked to him that day.
But basically...
We kept dying to Ice Spice.
A lot.
While we were playing.
Ice Spice is fucking crazy.
She's wild.
She's a baddie.
She actually is a baddie.
We kept dying to her.
And she had a sword, guys.
Okay, wait.
Let me give you guys a clip.
It's so funny.
I love the clip.
It's so good.
No, I can't get my...
I can't get my Discord.
Let me show you guys the clip.
Actually, I love this clip.
She's a baddie.
There we go.
This is...
This is what happened to us.
So, there's a lot of...
Oh, and I got this too.
This is like the Zoomer YMCA now.
I got that as well.
And then...
Oh my god, it's the chicken!
It's...
Oh my god, they have Arrested Development!
Oh my god, go Freeza.
Go.
Oh my god.
Go style.
Also, you can get cars now.
So, there's a lot of...
Oh my god, watch this.
I think this is my favorite from Snoop Dogg.
Guys, I have a problem.
Guys, the one thing I'm really sad about...
is that...
Goku can't wear shoes.
Like, he can't wear the kicks.
So, that's what I'm like...
really sad about.
One of my favorite parts about Snoop Dogg...
the Snoop Dogg skin...
is that...
I can turn into a real dog.
Look at that.
Look at him go.
He's already...
Look at that.
Oh yeah, and he's wearing my...
He's wearing the kicks right there.
Yeah.
Isn't it great?
Also, I have this one.
Which one is it?
Slim Sheik.
With the dog.
He got that dog in him.
This is a good reason...
that I'm your Oshi.
Ninja was in the store and I had to get him.
I also got Mr. Beast before all that stuff happened.
But I think it's still funny.
It's still a little funny though.
When you're like...
putting Mr. Beast after.
Now you're just evil.
I think it's even funnier...
now to die by...
Mr. Beast in Fortnite.
So...
I got John Cena.
I have...
Peter Griffin.
I have Mr. Beast.
I...
Guys, I have a problem.
Every time I...
come back to Fortnite.
Another thing I love about Eminem...
is when you have him...
do the Slim Shady song.
He actually...
sings the lyrics too.
Please stand up.
And then...
Guys, all I'm saying is that...
Fortnite is literally the...
It's literally one of the only games...
I actually spend cosmetics on.
Because like...
it's just so funny.
I don't know.
I just really enjoy...
I just really enjoy spending it on...
Fortnite skins.
Because I think it's just really funny.
It's just...
That's everything.
I could be Godzilla with Jordans.
I mean...
Anyway...
Since this is a sponsored stream, thank you again to Fortnite...
for sponsoring.
I'm sorry to my editor...
that has to censor...
all the third party stuff later.
Sadly, I cannot...
I won't be playing as...
Alright, let's see.
I'll be Candy Cane Man.
Mr. Dapper.
Mr. Dapper Man.
I'll be Mr. Dapper Man.
So...
They brought back OG Fortnite.
I think it's...
Which one is it?
OG Fortnite, guys?
Is it class...
Zero Beld Battle Royale.
Is it this one?
It's not out yet?
No, I played OG Fortnite.
Wait, what did I play yesterday...
Sure for.
What did I play?
Oh, is it Reload?
I think it was Reload.
Yeah, it was Reload.
Yeah, no, it was.
Okay, we're a new duo.
I need to get carried.
I was like, there's no way it was.
Reload is like, OG.
Yeah, so they brought back...
They brought back, um, the original Fortnite.
I never got a chance to play the original Fortnite, but, um, I never got a chance to play the original Fortnite.
And, uh, um, but I heard they made all the guns hitscan now.
So, um, almost all the guns.
It's all the guns, but, you know, I don't, I don't want, I cannot do build mode.
I'm so bad with build mode.
Like, I'm actually, I'm so bad with build mode.
It's actually, like, I would, I'd build one thing and then a child will build a fucking, sorry, a child, sorry to my editor, that's gonna have to start censoring me.
Um, a child will build a freaking apartment next to me and then I die.
So, like, I got eliminated.
So, um, I gotta remember, like, cause it's sponsored now.
And like, but the thing is, the best thing about it being a stream, because the sponsored portion is the video that's going to come from the stream.
I can say all these things, but then I'm making my editor have a harder time.
I forgot to take my backpack off!
Editor, can you censor the backpack?
Can you censor the backpack if you can?
I'm so sorry, editor.
Look, I'm moving around too, so it'll be easier.
It'll be so much easier.
I'm gonna move around, Mr. Editor, so you can be a poor editor.
Anyway, um, wait, is that Juice WRLD?
Oh my god, do I have Juice WRLD as my duo?
Oh my god, just put one main block.
It said move, just blur like 80% of the game.
Oh my god, I knew you'd be back.
Where's Juice WRLD in the drop?
Okay, so this is, oh, there's Tilted Towers.
We gotta go back to Tilted Towers.
Oh, I forgot to unequip that too.
Uh, I forgot.
I'm sorry, I'm so sorry.
I forgot to unequip.
Oh, can you block this out too, editor?
It's gonna be okay, but can you also block the Shedron as well for me?
I really appreciate it.
It would be so easy if you could.
All right, nothing bad's gonna happen, right?
Yeah, just have my audio clip on and then you play Fortnite, Mr. Editor.
That's just have- get the audio clip on from this game and then you play Fortnite and then sync it up.
And then I think that would be easier, honestly.
That would- That would be- I honestly think that would actually be easier to do versus the shit I'm making you- Editor, just delete the pod.
Oh my god.
Oh, Juice WRLD is not coming back for me.
Oh, Juice WRLD.
Oh, guys, I'm fucking- I'm freaking dead.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's another Juice WRLD!
Guys, I don't think- I don't think- I don't think Juice WRLD is coming back for me.
It's okay, I can- Oh, I can respawn.
I forgot.
This is reloaded.
Alright, Juice WRLD, I'm back.
Okay, Editor, make sure you censor every third-party IP I mention, Editor.
Just make sure I do that as well.
Make sure every time I mention a third-party entity, you also, like, censor the sound of that so it'll be like, hey, beep!
And then-
Like, it'll be that easy, Editor.
I believe in you.
I believe in you when you make this video.
It won't- It's not that difficult, trust me.
It'll be okay.
I believe- You guys believe in him?
I believe in him.
Editor, delete the vid.
They quit it.
You just lost yourself, Editor.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, that's just- That's just Juice WRLD.
Sorry, that's- Beep!
Beep!
What a great two-minute video, Editor.
Censored Jordans.
What's this?
Oh, hammer assault.
Okay, I have two of these.
Okay, somebody reloaded over there.
Just start referring yourself in the third person, Potato.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I am a little laggy.
Let me, like, fix that later.
Or, like, now, actually.
Is there somebody over there?
It's over there.
All right.
Okay, Editor, if you see a third-party IP, if I'm shooting a third part, just censor them.
Just, like, give them, like, a pixelated sensor so, like, they won't know what it is.
Like-
It's okay.
Oh my god, they're so tiny.
What?
Where are they?
Whoa!
Oh my god.
No!
I hit the hundred!
No, Juice WRLD!
I'm dead!
Juice... Juice WRLD!
Juice WRLD!
Sorry, beep!
Juice WRLD, I swear.
I swear to god.
I'm freaking flying.
Goodbye.
Oh, yeah, make sure to make this, like, super pixelated, too, when I'm flying down.
So, like, they won't know.
Don't worry, it's fine.
It'll be fine.
See?
He's gonna reboot in seven seconds.
You're not making it.
Also, remember to pixelate Fender, too.
Like, just remember, just-
Beep, WRLD.
There you go.
It's gonna work, guys.
It's gonna work, trust me.
It's gonna look like- It's gonna be a great video, guys.
Where is this guy?
He's shooting.
I'm just gonna run up.
There we go.
Anti-Andrew.
All right, nice.
That's good that he has, like, an actual- What did I do wrong?
I don't understand!
What did I do wrong?
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm just doing my job.
Okay, I need to grab- Is he okay?
Is Juice WRLD okay?
Sorry, is Beep WRLD okay?
He'll be fine.
What is this gun?
This is a pump shotgun.
All right.
I feel bad.
What?
What did I do wrong?
Oh, yeah, he's dead.
He's eliminated.
He's not?
Wait, is this a PAP pistol?
Yes, okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
What the frick?
That's- That's right.
Wait, actually, it might be easier for you to just censor him every time, I swear.
That might be easier for me, actually.
Oh, no, Juice WRLD, no.
Juice WRLD, no.
Just live.
All right, just- just- just put, like, beeps in there if I start swearing.
Like, it might be easier for both of us.
Just think about it.
Wait.
Sorry, I was choking on my own saliva because I'm not a real person.
Um, I can't function in society.
Okay.
Oh, hey, that's purple.
Wait, is that the same one?
Wait.
Wait, this is better.
This is better.
Beep WRLD, get over here.
Don't you love it when your VTuber's not real?
All right.
Where are they?
I feel like I need to lower the graphics quality.
Just so I don't lag.
Oh, this was all pre-recorded.
What if I was, like, government?
No, I shouldn't say that because some people might actually start freaking out.
But I'm gonna say, what if I was a government plant, just so I can harvest your data?
Anyway, make sure to not put that in the Fortnite VOD.
Make sure you don't put that in the Fortnite video.
I don't think that should be in it.
Yeah, I'm a psycops.
Yeah.
Where the heck are the people?
Nobody's, like, making noises.
Hello?
Oh, they're right below me.
That's what I like about the sponsor being a video.
I can say anything I want right now.
And then my editor.
I feel bad for my editor, but like...
But we can do this, editor.
We can work together.
We can... we can work together, editor.
Together!
It'll be fine.
We'll be so fine.
Wait, somebody is...
I'm looking below us, because... oh, there... there he is.
Oh my god.
What?!
That should have hit!
My crosshair was definitely on that!
My crosshair was on that, like, 100%.
I was on the target.
Like, he's in there.
Oh, no.
I'm like, wait.
How do I get down?
Watch this.
Okay, I'll take those.
I'll take it.
That's fine.
I... it's, you know, it's just a little damage.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Take more money from my favorite government agent.
That's okay, editor.
Make sure to cut that out.
Cut that out.
From the actual video.
What?
Is something gonna self-destruct?
What's that?
Oh, oh, I don't... I can't read.
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, no, Juice WRLD.
Juice WRLD, you only have one life, Juice WRLD!
Juice WRLD, no!
That's right, Juice WRLD.
Oh, he doesn't know.
Eliminated.
All right, yoink.
The only issue is that nobody has, like, heals.
Nobody has shields right now.
That's my only problem.
Yeah, there's no sh... oh, there's only mini shields.
Oh.
Wait, when did you die?
I was not paying attention.
Sorry, BeepWRLD, when did you die?
Oh my god.
Oh, I didn't expect that.
That's right.
No, that's not right!
BeepWRLD!
Wait, where did he...
Editor, don't put this in.
You fucker!
Oh my god, you... you went for the gear package?
Bro, bro is gone of my life.
And he's gone.
It was so... oh my god.
Bro!
You actually... bro, I made such a sick play, too.
I made such a frickin' sick play.
And he...
trusted BeepWRLD.
No, do not put that in.
Zekra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you mean I don't blame him?
I did so well.
I actually was gaming there.
I...
I was gaming.
All right.
OG Fortnite's map is so small.
I never realized how small the map is.
Um...
Now we can raise the game volume.
Okay, game volume has been raised.
Not OG.
I just noticed... I saw Tilted Tower, so I thought it was the OG map.
Because there was no Tomato Town.
What?!
I hope you... you get eliminated.
Okay, every time... Editor, every time I say die, I...
That's so embarrassing.
Okay, I'm gonna give you some words that you can substitute in.
So, like, every time I say die...
Put...
eliminated.
Eliminated.
All right, there.
I gave you some... I gave you... I, like, gave you some words.
So, like, you can sub in...
Eliminated every time I say die.
So, like, now you can just sub it.
So, and then, like, so if I keep saying eliminated...
I say so many different tones of eliminated.
That, like, it does... it will sound natural.
It's gonna sound super natural.
If you sub in the kill...
for eliminated, it'll sound so good.
Okay, let me get the... let me get Bender out of here.
What is... all right.
We'll put this one on and then let's get... let's get Shenron out of the way.
That's theirs, right?
That's... all right.
Well, it looks cool.
Oh, I like this one.
That's cute.
Please use a croquis.
Ah!
For your censored memes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Zeon.
All right, and let's get rid of this and then we'll do... oh, that's cool.
I like that.
Wait, no, this is cool.
Wait.
Oh, wait, the jetpack.
Actually, I want to do... I want this one.
All right, there we go.
We should be good now.
We should be good.
Wait, is that also family guy?
Oh, no.
Wait, that's family guy?
What is it?
May leave a stain.
No, it's art of... no, it's not.
There's no way.
That's not.
Wait, is that family guy?
The backpack?
No, that's not.
That's...
That's the llama.
No, that's Fortnite.
All right, the copyright.
Yeah, there you go.
We're good.
All right, let's go.
We're so good now.
Wait, I want to go to the new map.
Let's do the new map.
It should be this.
Zero build.
Solo.
Oh, wait, no.
You know what?
Let's do solo.
We can do solo.
You haven't said...
eliminated!
Eliminated!
Eliminated.
There we go.
That should be enough, right, for my editor?
That should...
Guys, do you think that's enough of a...
Do you guys think that's enough of a...
Audio... audio jungle for...
For my editor to use?
For the vibe?
Do you think...
It's...
It's... That should be fine, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Um...
That should be fine.
Anyway, guys, we can... I believe in us.
I definitely believe in us, guys.
No, he'll be fine.
He'll be fine.
He's not gonna quit.
This is the only thing that's not...
We have... This is why I'm stream... I'm gonna do a...
At least two hours.
Oh, I should... Let me...
Reset my graphics real fast.
Uh...
Low screen.
Um, I gotta make sure...
I'll do low.
I'm gonna do low graphics, so...
Hello?
Okay, there we go.
I'm gonna do low so, like, I don't lag too much.
And then... There we go.
Oh, there we go.
We should be fine, right?
Yeah, everything feels...
Everything will be okay.
Don't worry.
Everything will be okay, guys.
I'll do 200.
Maybe that'll be better.
Uh...
There you go.
All right.
So, like, they have this new area.
This area there, which is, like, they're, like, mini boss fights.
Help, this is Doki's editor from the future.
I forgot to keep something out and the feds got me more Doki before it's...
Thank you for the super chat burrito.
Thank you.
All right, there you go.
So...
This is one of the new areas.
I just saw this area before when I was, like, um...
When I was playing with Surefour and it's actually really crazy because it's basically a...
A mini boss fight.
So, oh my god.
Well, like, let's hope that maybe... Guys, do you think we... They'll want to work together?
Guys, do you think, like, these people are open to, you know, working together to kill the boss together?
Do you think they'll be okay with that?
This is a shotgun.
This is bad.
I only have a shotgun.
You guys think they would want to work together and we can be, like, you know, friends?
Oh...
Okay, that's...
That's the evil guy.
So, these are, like, evil things that can give you shields and stuff.
Guys, will we be fine?
Nice.
Eliminated.
See, at the end of the day, you don't have to...
Look at that.
And then...
I'm helping.
Oh my god.
No!
They slid in!
Oh, they got a point on me!
Guys, I don't know if I'm, like, cut out for a solo.
No, I don't know if I'm cut out.
Oh my god.
These guys, these children are so much better than me.
These children...
I just want to... I just want to run on the walls.
Let me run.
Why don't they want me to cooperate with me?
Why won't they cooperate with me?
We're a team!
I don't understand.
I thought we were a team.
Don't we want to do a boss fight together, teammates?
All right.
Yeah, don't worry.
I got you.
But still crazy.
It's so crazy to be sponsored by Fortnite because I play this game regardless if I'm sponsored or not.
And it's a bonus now.
Now I got... now I get paid to play a game that I was gonna play anyway, so...
I'm spending money on Fortnite anyway.
I have so many emotes.
I have a problem, guys.
I have... I definitely have a problem.
Like, I paid for these.
This is how they get me.
The V-Bucks.
They know what I want.
Honestly, if they wanted to pay me in V-Bucks, I'd say yes.
I...
I would 100% say yes if they paid me in V-Bucks because then I don't have to go through the hassle of...
I don't have to go through the hassle of, like, connecting my PayPal and then logging into my PayPal to buy me...
to buy me V-Bucks.
I can just... if they just put V-Bucks into my account, like, the amount of money they paid me for the sponsored, I'd be happy.
And then... and then I could use, like...
I could... it's like an unlimited... it's like an unlimited money glitch because if they...
if they pay me in V-Bucks, I can then use those V-Bucks and then use my creator code and then I get paid back for using my own creator code to buy myself...
to buy myself some Fortnite cosmetics and then I get from the money I get from using my own V-Bucks, uh, that was given to me by Epic, I can use it to buy more Fortnite cosmetics.
Anyway,
don't put this in.
Um, they might know my plan.
Don't put this in.
It's okay, just don't put it in.
The infinite Fortnite... yeah, exactly.
The infinite Fortnite money glitch.
Exactly.
It's just that easy.
I think my favorite though is the fact that it, uh, talked to... oh my god.
Um, thank you for your very first super chat, Arby!
Thank you, thank you.
He's like, I'll do a sponsorship, buy a list of emotes.
I'm going to need Epic.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay, guys, you can be in the demons dojo.
Guys, I didn't know you guys liked that place that much.
That's fine.
I'll just walk away.
That's okay.
You can... I'll just walk away.
It's all right.
Oh, it's not okay!
Who killed me?
That's for killing me while I'm trying to do sponsored content.
That's...
Report me.
That's true.
I'm trying to... I'm trying to explore the map.
All right, guys, we're gonna go do duo now because I don't think I'm gonna survive.
I really don't think I'm gonna survive, guys.
How is that more skilled?
He was in the bush!
Also, don't put that in as well, guys, because we want to make sure I'm not toxic.
I'm not a toxic gamer in the video.
So make sure to remove anything where I am a little toxic.
And then, like, if I say something toxic, just be like...
Okay, I'm gonna give you some sound clips, editor.
You're a great person.
Good job!
Oh my god, you should be a professional gamer!
Wait, that sounds really sarcastic.
You should really be professional.
Are you a professional?
Nice shot!
So, like, you know, if I say something really bad, just put that in and...
Just put that sound clip in there.
So I'll be like...
You hear the... You get the audio, right?
So, like, nice shot!
Oh my god, you're so good!
Wow!
Wait, oh, sorry.
I didn't remove the sarcasm.
That's a really nice shot.
Oh my god, are you a pro?
It's okay.
He'll understand.
Editor will understand.
Nice shot, bro!
Wait, is that still sarcastic?
Sorry, it's, like, second nature to me.
How do you not be sarcastic?
Yo, nice shot, man!
Bro!
Bro, you work out?
Are you a gamer, bro?
Hey, editor.
This is the funding for your work.
Thanks.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wow!
I definitely got outplayed there.
Oh my god.
Are you 13?
Because, damn.
That's a Fortnite gamer.
No, I shouldn't put that in.
That's actually really bad.
I'm just trying to imply that, like, young kids are really good at Fortnite.
That's...
You know, like, what was that kid's name that won a million dollars from Fortnite?
That shit was crazy.
Yeah, cut that one out.
I'm just saying that, like, those kids have, like, Fortnite reflexes.
Wait, is there no one here?
Oh, I can move faster now.
I'm scared.
Wait, is he doing the boss fight?
Bro, why are you doing the boss fight?
Oh, yeah.
This is what the boss fight looks like.
That... it's so cool.
Where is she?
Yeah, she has a gun.
I'm shooting her.
Frosty, I need you to help.
Oh!
Okay.
Frosty, Frosty, where is he?
That's fine.
I'm stuck.
Frosty, I'm stuck!
Okay, nice.
The night rose.
And then, like, he's gonna pick her up.
And you gotta shoot the eye.
Oh, damn.
Can I shoot from the back?
Oh.
And then, you gotta shoot her from here.
No!
She can't escape!
Okay, bro.
Frosty, I can't shoot at him!
Oh, I can.
Never mind.
I can shoot the back.
I didn't realize that.
Fine, Frosty.
I'm helping.
Shoot her!
Nice, we did it.
Yoink.
Here, I gave you the mask.
Oh, you don't want that mask, Frosty?
You don't want it?
I'll take it.
Yoink.
What's this?
Oh, no!
This one's really cool.
Yeah, I'll grab a shotgun, too.
Oh, my god.
I can be a bush.
Never mind.
I'll get the bush.
Wait.
Yeah, okay.
So, watch this.
And then, I do that.
And then, I go...
Oh, wait.
That's what happens.
It's a portal.
I think it's really cool because it's a portal.
To air a while next to a wall to kick off of.
Oh, wait.
I need to... I want to get the care package.
All right, we should get a care package now.
Yeah, it's like a little portal thing.
I was watching people, like, do this thing where you can res people with it, which I thought was really cool.
Wait, I hear... I hear a chest.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
More bushes.
This is my favorite bomb because I can put...
It's not suspicious at all.
This... This bush in my...
Is this a shotgun?
Okay.
This bush in my... In the concrete?
Not suspicious at all.
What are you talking about?
Team... Yeah, we're gonna plant trees.
I'm not Mr. Beast, so, like, you know I'm doing it for a good cause.
Cut that edit.
Make sure you don't put that in.
Like, you're just gonna, like... You're gonna get to the beginning of it, and then we just suddenly cut to the end of this game.
And they'll never... We'll cut to the end of the game.
All right, nice.
What gun is this?
This is a assault rifle.
Okay.
What even is going into the video?
New content!
So, like, you guys... Okay, anyway, get this audio clip of me explaining about...
Okay, so I'm gonna talk about the... I'll talk about the cool-ass demon girl we just fought.
And then you're gonna put that audio on top of the part here.
On the top of the part where I talked about Mr. Beast.
So, like, they won't know.
It's gonna sound so natural.
And then, I know, like, the mouth movement is not gonna be the same.
But, like, we can, like...
Um, we can... We can, like, just edit that.
Edit the mouth movement to fit the audio clip.
So, anyway, um, I thought it was really cool.
Because, yeah, like, there's always been, like, mini boss fights and stuff.
And mini boss fights for Fortnite.
And then, like, I think the boss fight was really cool for that.
Because, like, you can get these masks.
And, like, they don't know...
They don't know who I am until I put that mask on.
Make sure you don't include that part.
Because that's a reference to something else.
Um, but, like, I put on this...
I put on this mask.
And then, um, and I can portal and stuff.
So, like, that's why I thought it was, like, a really cool, uh, really cool item.
That's what the point of the mask is.
I think my manager's gonna be mad at me.
He gave me, like, a list of, like, okay, make sure you say this.
And make sure you don't say these things.
And then, like, in my head, like, for...
So that your editor will, like, you know...
So it'll be easier for, like, your editor to figure out what to do.
I was like, yeah, I should be able to do that.
Oh my god, look at this rap!
There we go.
I was like, yeah, I think I can do that.
That should be fine.
Um, but then I realized it's a lot harder than I thought.
So, like, good luck.
Oh, you can do, like, trick shots and stuff, uh, for...
Wait, there's a train.
Oh yeah, they have a train now, too.
You can get, like, loot on the train.
Is there anybody here?
Beep beep.
Anyone here?
Hello?
I'm following traffic rules.
Wait, where is the train?
Oh, I missed the train.
Sorry, Frosty.
I missed the train.
Wait, is this actually a dragoon?
My god, what are the odds?
Wait, what's over there?
Oh, that's another boss fight!
We can take him!
Oh yeah, you can get him!
You can kidnap a child.
Sorry, you can take a child.
You can have a...
Look, you can kidnap...
Sorry, you can...
You can have a child and then he'll do a little dance for you.
Watch this.
You can return the child, but that's not fun.
Um, anyway, let's kill this guy.
Let's get this boss fight.
Oh!
It's okay.
Oh, they portal too.
There's so many children!
Oh yeah, you can return them to their home, but you don't have to do that.
Okay.
Don't worry, we got this.
We got this, Frosty.
Oh my god!
Is he gonna...
Frosty, no!
Frosty, I have a child!
Over here.
Oh!
No, I messed up.
No, I messed up!
I messed up!
I got scared!
No, I couldn't use the child!
I got scared because they jumped down!
They jumped down!
I couldn't use...
I couldn't make the child dance!
I wanted to...
Sorry, maybe I shouldn't say that.
Um, what is it called?
An elemental?
I couldn't make the elemental dance for us, so I...
When it...
When it dances, it heals you and it's so cute.
I couldn't show it to you guys.
I wanted you guys to see the child.
Sorry, I wanted...
Sorry, editor.
My filter's not working very well right now.
I couldn't...
Oh my god, we couldn't see the elemental dance for us.
Okay, I'm gonna say the word elemental, and then you're gonna have to substitute.
All right.
Elemental.
So, whatever I say, whatever I say, child, substitute elemental.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay, don't laugh.
It makes it harder.
At this point, just voice over the video.
Okay, if we don't have enough content, we'll play Fortnite off-stream to make up for it.
Just give me a list of things that you need clips of and then, like, you're gonna take the audio of that and then we can, like, place it up on it.
That's... it's okay.
But, like, we're getting our reactions, our natural reactions to things.
I love...
I think, like, the gunplay in Fortnite is really nice because they always have, like, so many different types of guns.
Sapphire, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I fucked up badly today.
No!
It's salvageable!
This is so salvageable!
Thank you, Fortnite, for the sponsor.
I really appreciate it.
I...
I really do.
Alright, here we go.
Is he coming with me?
He is, right?
Nice.
You know what's funny?
At first, we were just, um...
Cause, like, you know how I said, like, my manager was on vacation?
So then, I was like, yeah, I can do, like, an edited VOD.
That's fine.
Like, not an edited VOD, but I can just, like, you know, record footage and then put audio over it.
And then, my...
When my...
Oh my gosh, no, that's...
That's Avatar.
Sorry, that's Beep.
And then, when my manager, uh, came back from vacation, um...
He was like, no, what do you mean?
He was like, you know what?
Can we make you the stream?
And then, they were like, no, that's fine.
And then, we'll just, like, edit the VOD.
We'll just edit the VOD.
And then, they were like, yeah, that's fine.
But then, like...
Oh, hey.
Oh, are you also?
Edited.
Make sure to cut this out, because it's copyrighted.
And then, I was like...
And then, it's like, no, it'll be easier.
And I was like, are you sure?
It's like, yeah, yeah, this will be easier for you.
And now, I feel like it might not be easier.
I...
I don't know.
Now...
I don't think it is actually easier.
Because they're like...
And then, they got back from vacation.
And they were like, oh, yeah, yeah, like...
I know they're like, oh, yeah, can we just do, like, a VOD?
Like, can we just, like, have her stream it?
And then, like...
Am I gonna be okay?
So, now, I don't know.
Oh, sh...
What?
Where did I get shot from?
Wait, no, this is...
Oh, this is not reloaded.
This is not.
I got beamed.
Wait, you never got a gun?
Bro!
I didn't realize he never got a gun.
So, then...
So, now, I was like...
My manager thought it was a great idea.
Because they're like, it's easier.
So, you don't have to...
So, the reactions are more natural.
But then, I think he forgot that, like...
My reaction might be more natural.
But it's definitely not...
It might be...
It might be just a little bit unhinged.
Just a little bit for a more natural reaction.
They forgot who exactly they're dealing with.
It might be...
It's like when, like, you know...
I've been a streamer for so long.
To the point where, like...
Like, you know, I'm not a...
I'm not brand risk.
But it's more so of, like...
I know my audience.
To a point where, like...
I know what I'm comfortable.
Like, what is the comfortable stuff to say and stuff.
But, like...
It might not be the most, like, you know...
It might not be comfortable for everybody.
You know.
So, it's like, you know, like...
Some people will have their filters in check.
I've been streaming for so long.
That, like, I don't have filters anymore.
Because, like...
Well, I do to an extent.
But my filters that's in place...
Might not be the correct filters that I should have.
Just...
Maybe...
I don't know.
Seaport City?
So, like, my intrusive thoughts are, like, going wild.
I think my duo left me.
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
Any dragoons in my lobby?
Can I...
Will you, like, make sure I survive?
Alright.
If any dragoons are in my lobby right now...
If you see a PineappleGhost77 and you're in my lobby right now...
Just, like, form a wall.
Form a circle around me.
That's all I want.
Just form a circle.
Why am I walking?
How do I fix that?
Oh my god.
Why am I walking?
Yeah, the great dragoon wall.
Press...
Did I fix it?
No.
Oh, I did.
I accidentally pressed comma.
I don't know how I did it.
So...
I'm at Seaport Dragoons.
Just...
Okay, I'm not saying that as in, like...
Mach 7, go kill me now.
But, like, form...
Make sure you form a wall around me.
And I'll be safe.
Okay.
And we got shields here.
Yeah, just form a wall.
And then I'll know you're...
Yeah, you're definitely...
You're definitely not a dragoon.
Hahahaha!
Oh no.
He's, like, right here, isn't he?
He's not?
Oh nice, okay.
There's no way.
All right, form a wall of your dragoon.
And then like, I don't know, make sure I don't die.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna make the jump!
That's right!
Made the jump, but I'm scared.
Where are they?
Oh, this is my train now.
My train now!
That's right!
Oh nice, I get to live here.
Nice!
I made the jump.
All right, so you can hack this for like more loot, I'm pretty sure.
All right, guys.
All right, now I'm not at seaport anymore.
I'm at- I'm heading to brutal boxcars.
If you're a dragoon in my lobby, meet me at brutal boxcars.
Meet me there.
Wait, I think it's heals.
Did they open this already?
We need- we need a circle.
Oh nice.
Oh, they never hacked it!
Wait, that's sick.
That's good.
It's good for me actually.
I need this.
I'll take that.
All right, we're fine.
Meet me there.
We're- we're gonna go on a heist.
Is anybody- form a car!
It's like protect the president!
Get cars and drive next- oh my god!
No!
Guys.
Guys, I think they want to get on the- oh, you're so slow.
Nerd.
That's right.
Couldn't even get on the train.
I don't think those are dragoons, guys.
Oh no, no, no!
All right, friendly?
Friendly people?
Are there friendly people in the stop?
Hello?
Hey guys, you guys all friendly?
All right, nice.
Next stop.
Next stop, Brutal Boss Cars.
I'll see you guys there.
Wait, we got shot one time and we're okay now.
Nice.
You know what that means.
But it's like not co- what is- oh no.
Oh no, what is it?
Oh, this one.
Default.
This is the safest one.
This is the safest dance.
Anyway, you don't have to edit this one out.
We're fine.
Look at that.
Look at us go.
Yeah, dance once if you're a friend.
Dance twice if you're not a friend.
So that I can have time to shoot you before you shoot me back.
All right, any- but the- any dragoons here?
Any dragoons to welcome me?
Brutal Box Cars?
Hello?
Anyone here to welcome me?
You know, like I got back from my trip and then I have people visiting me.
You know, like that?
Hello, guys.
Anybody?
Anyone?
Oh, I think all the dragoons are dead.
There's nobody.
You know, there's nobody here to like greet me at the- oh, it's like, you know, you got off your flight.
You got off your flight and nobody is there to welcome you home.
Oh my god, there's a child!
Guys, I'm gonna show you the child.
Yoink.
Okay, watch this though.
Dance for me.
Wait.
Oh, child.
Child.
Okay.
Okay, the child needs a spot to dance.
That is- oh!
Oh, no!
Okay, the child cannot dance.
The child cannot dance on Kidnapping Successful.
Okay, don't put that in.
Kidna-
We kidnapped him live on stream.
Oh my god, we're so good.
Okay.
All right, watch this.
Okay, we kidnapped an elemental, but watch this.
It's so cute.
Dance for me.
Yeah!
One!
Two!
You're so cute.
There you go.
That's what he does.
That's so cute.
I don't feel safe, like, at all.
Like, I feel like, you know, I'm literally in the open right now.
All right, let's- oh, somebody has a rifle.
Oh my god, this is way too quiet.
There's still 34 people alive?!
Holy sh- I'm gonna get a car.
I'm gonna try and feel more safe.
Me and my- me and my elemental.
Me and my child.
This child feels safe.
Oh my god, I turned on the radio.
Okay, um, when I-
It's okay, it's gonna be edited.
It's gonna be edited.
Literally,
it yearns for the mines.
That is so- that minecra- the Minecraft lore for the movie with Jack Black and then he's like, like, the whole- the whole lore of, like, Minecraft Steve is that he was a child that really wanted to be a a a coal miner.
Like, that's his story.
And then he got transported into Minecraft, which I thought was like, why would you want- People die in the mines.
What the fuck?
I can swear because I know you can't put that in the vine.
I- that is nuts.
He yearns for the mines.
It's a little stupid.
That's all I'm gonna say.
And then, like, I'm just thinking, like, why is the apple a cube?
Like, I don't understand.
Why is the apple a cube?
I'm gonna do to you what he did to me.
Never mind.
Oh, never mind.
That's okay, I have air time.
Oh, what the fuck?
I don't have air time.
Wait, there's- you're a freak.
What kind of freak follows me?
Oh, no.
Wait, he's still- is he still following?
I can't tell.
No, it's not.
My car's okay.
Guys, it's okay.
I- it's salvageable.
I can fix it.
I can fix this.
Oh my god, there's a- there's another child.
Get over here.
Get over-
I'm done playing with the other child.
So, like, in the- in the other child.
So, like, this child.
This, like, this elemental.
He makes you fly.
But it's, like, one time you steal because, you know, you gotta go back to him.
Hahaha.
Okay, and then, like, get over here, child.
And go- get over here, elemental.
I'm coming back for you.
And then you pick him up and then you can return him to his home.
Right here.
You pick up this child and you're like, feed him.
Oh, they already fed him.
Never mind.
He's already been fed.
I'm no use for you anymore.
I like the other one more.
Hahaha.
Into the waters you go.
Wait, where's the other one?
Hey, where's the blue one?
I like the blue one more.
Oh, I guess I'll take you for now.
You're mine.
There you are, blue one!
There's so many!
Oh my god, get over here.
That's right.
Okay, three.
Oh my god, look at all these orphans.
Look at all these elementals.
Look at these orphans here.
Okay.
Where are they?
Oh, the strogan arena's here!
Okay, that's like another place.
This place is like freaky as hell.
Oh my god, it's so far.
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it.
It's way too far.
They're gonna have like gold and purple guns by now I get there.
Are you crying?
What's that?
Oh, it's fighting over there!
I see them.
They're like right over here.
Okay, let's head over.
We see he's happy!
He's smiling!
Look at him.
He's like a little guy.
Oh, they killed somebody.
Okay.
Look at that!
See, look!
He's so happy!
He's like, again, again!
Yeah?
Yeah, again?
Right, child?
Look at that.
Oh my god, there he is.
Oh my god, thank you for the rainbug!
Thank you, thank you!
I figured it out, guys.
Oh no, child.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Oh no, that's not where I want to go, but that's fine!
That's fine!
Child, dance for me!
Do your little jinky dance!
Do your little dance!
Okay, come back in my pocket.
Child!
They danced for me.
It's fine.
It worked.
I can make him dance again.
Oh.
Now dance again.
There we go.
That's right.
Good dancing.
I don't have bullets left.
No, no, you're not running away.
You're not running away.
All right.
No, this is duos.
I messed up.
Oh, thank god.
I need this.
Actually.
All right, good.
We're okay.
That's fine.
The child is now safe.
Guys, it was dangerous!
He didn't know what- that child didn't know what was good for him, okay?
I went over there and like saved him.
He could have tripped and fell.
I literally saved that guy.
I'm a hero.
You're welcome.
Okay, where do I- okay, there's ammo.
Nice.
I was running out of ammo.
All right.
Is it really okay?
We can find another one.
I don't know what happens when you use all of them.
I've never had that opportunity.
Oh my god.
Yes!
Okay, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
Now I have anime on my side.
This is good.
This is good for us.
Um, we don't need a shotgun because we have anime now.
And then...
Okay, nice.
Okay.
We have- no, you guys don't understand.
We- I- I died to ice spice like two times with this.
I- You guys don't understand.
His anime is that strong.
Oh no, I'm a little scared though.
I don't know.
Oh, they're over there.
They're over there.
You think he saw me?
Guys, I think they saw me.
I think they saw me.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure they saw me.
I need to be on the other side of them.
I'm scared.
I don't have enough time for my child to dance a little long.
Dance one last time and then...
I need to- I want to dance one last time with with my elementa.
And then, uh, and see what happens to him.
I just wonder what happens to him.
I have my sword.
I have my katana with me.
I have it.
We'll be fine, right?
We're not gonna get sniped, right guys?
We'll be fine.
I'm literally- I think it's like...
Three duos and then me.
Wait, this is it.
I'm gonna go in.
Oh, no, they're just fighting over- what the fuck?
What the fuck
is going on?
Is it safe?
I'm waiting for the third party.
Because there's no one knocked yet.
I feel like I'm gonna get third partied here.
Unless...
There he is.
He doesn't know.
Just casually walking up.
Just gotta make sure I'm safe here, too.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, no, I lost track of people.
Where did he go?
Oh, no.
Enemy.
Okay.
All right, we're fine.
We're fine.
Enemy.
We have enemy on our side.
Where are they?
Wait, where did they go?
Where's my fighting?
How am I supposed to third party when they don't fight?
Wait, maybe right here?
Yo, Kiamber Doge, I'm trying to find a fight right now.
I'm a little scared, though.
Wait, that's not fair.
They have two teleporters.
How the fuck am I supposed to compete with that?
Guys, I don't- I don't know anymore.
Wait, they knocked somebody.
They knocked somebody so far!
No, this is not path- I'm- I'm a solo.
I'm a solo in this scary world.
Me, I am a single dad.
Um...
Who adopted this orphan out of the goodness of my heart.
And then...
but...
But I need to figure out how to get there.
I need to figure out how to fucking survive.
This bush is safe.
Oh my god, this is a safe bush.
It's two duos and me.
Okay.
There's two- two are here.
Two are up the hill.
And then there's me in this bush.
Okay, okay.
Like, what am I supposed to do in this situation?
Oh my god, what am I supposed to-
That's looking right.
Yeah!
I creeped up!
He must be like- he must be like, what the fuck?
Where did he even come from?
That's right.
Juice world!
Oh my god, it's okay.
At least somebody gets to be a winner.
At least- right guys, that's all that matters.
He gets to be a winner.
Oh my god, where- oh wait, the battle pass is sick.
Okay.
What?
Soon.
This is my goal.
This is unlocks at January- that's my goal.
Wait, enable auto claim.
Oh my god.
No, I have to wait until January 17.
But like- ooh!
Wait, that's sick.
I think like my favorite one was...
My favorite- oh my god.
Oh wait, that's not the child.
Oh, it's a sticker!
Oh, that- she's cute though.
I also really like their original skins too.
Um, their original skins are really cool as well.
It's like the actual like, um...
design and stuff.
Everything.
Who's that?
Who's that buddy behind him?
Okay, but then they have Baymax.
I love how...
All of these is like original skin and then there's Baymax.
He's just- he's just there.
He's just there.
Oh, and then this is the night rose.
This is the lady that we eliminated earlier.
Um, wait, what's this?
Is this like the- oh, it's a backpack.
Wait, is this like- oh, the puppet dance.
Yeah, she's the boss girl!
So, what's the last one?
The tactical night rose.
I wonder if they have the- oh, they're- oh, is this a glider?
Oh!
Okay, that's sick.
That's a sick glider though.
I like the glider.
Okay.
All right, I got a list.
I just- I was just sent a list of...
2, 4, 6, 8, 10, 12, 14, 16, 18.
Sorry, I got sent a list of...
Of like, um...
For like, I get to- I- I figure out what pro to play with on- on...
Is this Friday or Thursday?
On Thursday or Friday?
I don't remember.
All right, I'm going to do trio now.
Trio should be better.
Because like, they can't disappoint me, right?
They can't- there's no way.
There's no way they'll disappoint me this time.
Do you think a two-hour vod- do you think a two- two hours of content will be enough for my editor?
Or like...
Is he fucked?
To make like, 10 minutes.
Do you think he'll be okay with the things I gave him?
No.
Do you think he'll be okay?
Oh, okay.
Remember to censor my- Okay, whenever this guy shows up next to me, remember to like, put like, those like, mosaic- mosaic blur right there.
I'm gonna get more water.
I'll be right back.
If anything happens to me, I'm sorry.
I think he'll be fine.
He'll be okay.
Thanks, Fortnite, for the sponsor.
The editor's dead.
He'll be fine, guys.
Don't be- no dooming here.
He'll be okay.
I believe in our editor.
We're always not gonna have a bot to edit- Darkblade, thank you for the super- super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He'll be okay.
Look, if a worse thing happens, I'll just put some extra stuff off stream.
Look, my manager thought it would- it was- it would save so much time if I just stream it.
And then like, um, so it's not like, scripted in terms of like, me reading off stuff, but like, little does he know.
Offstream Doki.
My stream- streamer Doki is a little unhinged.
It's like, oh, it's gonna be much more natural, you know?
It'll be so much more natural.
You stream your reactions to like, the new content.
True!
Did I just get away?
If it works, it works, you know?
If it won't work, it works.
Is there an extra gun here?
Oh my god, I don't have a- Oh my god, oh!
No!
Wait, are they all alive?
Wait, she's still alive.
Cut the part where I die, but leaving that sick kill I got on my melee.
And then he like, read the brief, and then he was like, oh.
And then before, before like, my stream started, my manager was like, oh shit, I died so conveniently.
My manager was like, did you read what you can and can't say?
And I was like, yeah.
And then he was like, but did you read it?
He's like, okay, but like, you know, you, you, you, you know like, what you can and can't say, right?
I'm like, yeah.
And in my head, I was like, the editor can edit it out.
I was like, the editor can- Can edit, can edit it out, right?
No,
I did!
I did read it!
I did, I, I, I 100% did.
Also, this island.
Oh, sorry.
Okay, island.
So whenever I say map, make sure I substitute it with island.
Island.
Island!
I forgot it's an island.
Like, it's like, like, it's just this random place in the middle of nowhere.
I forgot about that.
Like, this is an actual island area.
Fuck, editor.
I believe in you.
I, I don't- I believe in you.
And I- look, I did say, I did- where are we chopping?
We can chop stuff?
Oh my god, it's like a hidden bamboo grove.
Wait, that's so cool.
Wait, that's so cute.
I like that.
That's so cute.
It's like a little hidden area that you can- oh, this guy's a Fortnite player right there.
Oh my god, wait, that's a boss guy literally next to us.
Wait, I don't think he's a good guy.
Wait, where am I?
He does not look like a good guy.
Okay, I'm just gonna run because I have nothing and there's a car in front of me.
Get in here!
We're going to the mall!
We're all going to the mall!
Midnight, get your ass in the car!
That's right!
Shopping trip, mall time!
Where is this?
Oh, it's over here.
This is like, get in losers.
Beep beep.
Wait, you can boost in this tiny ass car?
Sweet.
All right, we can grab for stuff like...
here at the gas station.
Oh, there's like a little area here.
Grab your stuff!
Go!
Loot this!
Loot it!
That's right!
Make sure you censor that guy.
Make sure he's just like this pile of mosaic running around.
Ha ha ha!
All right, I might be able to swap cars here too if it's a nice car.
All right, grab your stuff.
Wait, I need to grab stuff too.
Is there anything here?
There's nothing at the gas station?
I guess there's food.
Can I eat?
Wait, does this give me shields?
No, okay.
Are you just waiting?
You guys can drive too!
Oh my!
Ha ha ha!
I love how those two are just waiting there.
They're just like, any day now.
Ha ha ha!
She'll come back for us, right?
Where's the loot?
Like, where is the loot?
Okay, we're gonna go to the fucking city.
We'll be fine.
Here we go.
I like how they literally just sat there and waited for me.
Like, ha ha ha!
They're just like, any day now.
She'll come back, right?
All right, guys, it's shopping time.
This is our shopping time.
Oh, nice.
Okay, nice.
We filled up our shields.
Oh!
Wait, is this a...
Let's see, what's this?
Oh, that's just cool.
Watch this.
Look at that.
Yeah, screw that wall.
Oh, shit!
Oh my God.
I'm so sorry, Boris.
Okay, they're bots.
Oh, thank God.
Loot delivery!
It's okay.
It's okay, man.
There's nothing to be afraid of.
They were bots.
They were just bots.
There's no way they're real.
Oh, is that shield fish?
Okay.
We're fine, right?
We need to get a better car.
I want a sicker car.
Oh!
I asked and I received.
There we go.
All right, guys, come on!
Get in here!
Oh, there's a bike next to me, too!
We can be like...
Like a bodyguard in the president!
Fill your shield?
No.
Okay, let me chug jug.
That was a cool car earlier.
You've ruined it.
That's fucked up, man.
Now we have some...
I mean, I guess...
No!
The one before was cooler!
That one was cooler!
He overrode the trip!
No, he could've just ran.
Oh, my God, you could've ran.
Weak.
I miss.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God!
Bro!
I still got him!
No!
Okay, I still killed him.
I don't know!
He, like, got in the car!
The enemy guy got in the car!
Oh, wait, I love that gun.
Got in the car, and then...
And then he, like, drove with me in it.
And then I killed him.
I can't believe I got away!
That's crazy!
That's actually crazy!
Oh, my God!
Double J, thank you in the super chat!
There's no way you get away with it!
What can I say?
I'm just a gamer.
And the guy...
Actually, I had, like...
30 HP, and I still won!
Like, what the fuck?
Okay.
That's fine.
Okay, now I don't know, editor.
Our teammates...
What do we do here?
Editor, what do...
Oh, my God!
Editor, what do we do here?
This is a little bit of a problem.
Okay.
Oh,
my God, you're right!
We create a custom with just us!
You're right!
Okay, if I see you...
If I see you...
Okay, I'm gonna create...
After this game, I'm gonna create a custom for just us, guys.
And then we're...
It's not gonna be scripted.
It's not gonna be scripted, guys.
Oh, shit.
Where are we dropping?
Oh, I... Sorry, guys.
You know how I pinged that area?
Sorry, I know I pinged that area.
But, like...
Don't worry, I'm heading over there.
Guys, no, no, don't be...
Guys, no, no, no, don't be pussies.
No, here!
Here!
That's right.
Listen to me.
We're dropping here.
That's right.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, just make sure you don't have any...
Make sure you are using...
Non...
Non-third IP skins, guys.
Wait.
Okay, they're at the edge over there.
So maybe I can grab...
I'll grab something over on the backside.
There's no way somebody land in the back.
There's no way.
We'll be fine.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, I'm gonna drink this.
Okay, I got some shields.
Yeah, see?
Everything's fine.
And I got some banana.
Oh, nice.
Let me grab this.
I believe in them.
Okay.
This is a shotgun, right?
Okay, we're good.
Don't worry, I'm coming over!
No!
Monkey boy, no!
Guys, I still believe in us.
In our way, I still believe in us.
Wait, what?
Oh, you're a dragoon!
Thanks.
Did he die?
He might have died.
He might be dead.
Mustard pack, get shit on.
Get shit on, mustard pack.
Die, get shit on!
Oh my god, let me out.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, I got you guys.
Don't worry, I got you guys!
Coconut.
Where's the other card?
Is that it?
Oh!
Okay.
You know the best part?
Is that...
The best part about this is that...
Because he has a jigsaw skin...
He doesn't exist in my...
He's irrelevant.
What a slide.
It's okay, he's very irrelevant.
Just because he's on jigsaw.
Alright.
How do I make a custom lobby again?
It's been so long.
I think it was...
Oh my god guys, I don't remember how to make it.
Guys, do you guys remember?
I think it was...
Zero build?
With a code.
I know, I'm trying to remember how to do this.
It's been so long.
Wait, what are the quests?
Oh, you can do quests to...
Oh!
You can do quests to like, unlock stuff.
I didn't know you could do that.
That's cute.
Oh, that's cute, you can do all that.
Oh, if you have like, Fortnite on...
iPhone.
You can have like, these things.
Matchmaking key.
Yes, but...
Put your own code as a lobby.
Oh, there it is!
Custom key.
There we go, okay!
Our custom key.
Sponsored.
That's our custom key, guys.
Alright.
Did I put it?
Sponsored.
Yeah, alright, you go here.
At the bottom, and it says custom key.
Our custom key is...
Sponsored.
That's...
That's our custom key.
And then we're gonna do...
We're gonna do duos.
We're gonna go duos.
Our region!
Our region is...
I'll make you guys play on my region.
What the fuck?
Okay, west.
NA west.
That's our region, guys.
Alright, that should be it.
Wait, queue is full?
That's just me.
It's literally sponsored.
Where are you guys?
Oh, we got it!
The code is sponsored.
That's the code, chat.
I believe in us.
That's literally the code.
What could go wrong?
What?
No copyrights!
Okay, here are the rules.
Here are the rules, guys.
I hope you guys are taking the skins off.
Okay, no...
Copyright...
Skins.
Alright?
That's the main concern.
We gotta make this natural.
Okay, let me turn streamer mode on.
Where's streamer mode for the music?
We might have to turn it on just so we can...
License audio.
Mute others.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, I'm gonna mute you guys.
Mute others.
Okay, now we're actually...
We're so natural now.
Alright, no copyright skins.
Alright, that's it.
That's it.
Okay, code is...
Code is...
Wish I'd done this in the first place.
Code is sponsored.
That's the code.
And then, that's the custom key.
Sponsored.
Custom...
Custom key.
Also, guys.
If you guys didn't know.
I have a creator code.
So what you do is that you go to the shop.
And then you support a creator down here.
And then you put Doki Bird.
And then...
And then, bam!
You support me.
The mode is...
Zero build.
It's zero build.
Duo.
And then, oh yeah, I should write...
West Coast.
Duo.
No build.
We're not building.
There we go.
That's everything.
That's all the information here.
Alright.
Wait, do I start?
Oh, I could've started the smash.
Sorry.
Alright.
Wait for it.
79 people in the lobby.
I'll go start.
Wait, what was the maximum amount of people you can have in there?
I don't remember.
What's the maximum number?
Okay, and then I put this up.
Wow, guys.
I just queued up random...
Oh, I thought...
Oh, I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Now, we could've had more of you guys here.
Alright.
I'm investigating your skins now.
Alright, fashion show time.
Show me your skins.
It's fashion show time.
Guys.
Oh, wait, this is a new one.
Oh, it's so cute.
This is a newer one.
Nice, nice fashion.
Oh, nice, nice.
Did you guys use my code to buy those?
You guys used my code, right?
Drip check.
Alright, show me your best drip.
Nice drip.
Are these all originals?
Those are actually really...
I really like...
Oh, she's cute.
She's very cute.
Who's on my team?
Oh, it's...
Jesus.
This is the last.
I believe in this.
Alright, guys.
We're gonna work together.
Okay?
Guys.
In the spirit of Fortnite chapter 6.
Let's all work together and kill the boss together.
It'll be so natural.
It'll be...
Guys, it'll be like...
Can't believe it!
In the spirit of Fort...
Sorry, eliminate the boss together.
In the spirit of Fortnite chapter 6.
Somehow everybody's gonna work together and fight...
Oh my god, maybe there's too many people.
Oh my god.
Okay.
And if you don't find a gun, use your fists.
Okay?
If you have no gun, you just start fisting.
Just start meleeing.
Guys.
It's just that easy.
I bet we can melee her.
Guys, I don't even think we need a gun.
Guys, let's all go in and start meleeing.
Let's all go in.
Screw it.
Guys, melee!
God, not me!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Alright, we did it, guys!
Oh my god, the items all got absorbed so fast.
Alright, in the spirit of Fortnite...
In the spirit of Fortnite, we're gonna eliminate the other bosses.
Who's the next one?
Who's next?
I know there's two more bosses.
Let's go find the other bosses, guys.
Alright, in the spirit of Fortnite, we're gonna keep finding...
In the spirit...
Alright, guys, follow me!
Follow me, guys!
We're gonna go find the other bosses.
I'm tired.
Shouldn't have died.
Who would the other bosses be?
That's right!
Look at...
Oh my god.
God and anime is on my side now.
Alright, guys, we gotta fill her up.
Guys, sorry, let me...
Oh wait, I don't need to...
Can you guys break this for me?
Guys, can you break this for me so I can go through?
In the spirit of Fortnite, can you guys break the front area?
Yeah, thank you.
I love Fortnite.
Where does the next boss spawn, guys?
Guys!
Who knows where the next boss spawns?
Who knows where it spawns, guys?
Does anyone know?
We gotta figure this out together, guys.
In the spirit of Fortnite, who knows where the next boss is?
Oh my god, a child!
Yoink.
Okay.
Okay, alright.
It has a seat in the map!
That's what I'm trying to... Whoa!
It spawns on the...
Alright, guys!
Since it spawns on the third circle, we gotta wait.
Wait, let's return a child.
Okay, guys, I'm gonna go return a child.
Alright, I'm gonna show you what it looks like.
I forgot to show you guys.
Alright.
I don't say that.
Wait, okay.
So, like, after you find a elemental, you go over here and you go, return spirit.
Return sprite to your home now.
Go back to your home and then he gets absorbed.
And you're like, go back to where you came from.
Go back.
Oh my gosh, I shouldn't have done that dance.
Hahaha!
Yeah!
And then you pick up another one.
We did it, guys!
We returned him home!
Go home!
Wait, that's the gun.
Wait, I actually need that.
No!
That was bait!
Hahaha!
No!
Then they took the gun?!
That's messed up.
That was actually bait right there.
Alright!
We gotta go fill up the- Oh my god, we gotta go- Guys, I gotta go to a gas stop real quick, guys.
I'm running out of gas.
Alright.
I gotta go to the- I gotta go refill the gas tank.
Don't worry, I have money.
Wait, actually, I might be short.
Will you guys spot me some couple of dollars?
Wait, you guys- Can you guys spot me a couple of dollars for gas, guys?
Whoops, sorry.
I'm actually not sorry.
Alright.
Don't worry, man.
Oh my god, there's too many people alive.
Let's go!
Oh my god, that was a sick flip.
Okay, guys, guys, I need- Guys, please.
Please, I need to fill up my gas.
There we go.
Alright.
Don't worry, filling it up.
Filling her up.
We're fine.
What did I say about copyright?!
Execute her.
She used copyright material.
It's time for her to go.
I'm not gonna do the dirty job.
This woman right there.
Execute her.
Right here.
She used copyright.
Somebody take the shot!
Take the shot!
Wait, where did she go?
She's over there!
She's in that car!
Pull the car up!
Okay.
I'll do the dirty job.
I can't believe you guys can't finish- Wait, they all look the same.
Which one's the real one?
Wait, stop!
Stop!
Wait, there's more than one!
Wait, there- Wait!
Stop!
No!
Guys, I messed up.
I guess I- I- I caused anarchy.
Oh no.
My bad.
My bad, guys.
I didn't realize there were multiple
That was my bad.
I didn't realize.
Oh, there he is!
Let's go!
In the spirit of Fortnite!
Oh my god!
Let me in.
Okay, we gotta go here.
Guys, next boss fight.
Drive!
It's time to show you guys the next boss fight.
Guys, we're all heading there.
That's right, everybody.
Come on!
I like how one guy died.
I'm so sorry for that one person that died.
Guys, why are you following the road?
Why?
Why do we have road safety right now?
Ma'am!
You don't need to follow the road!
Drive!
No!
It's a car pileup!
I messed up!
Oh no!
The pileup!
Guys, this is why we follow road safety laws, guys.
I realized I realized why now we have traffic laws.
Alright, we gotta go.
Go here!
Now we gotta go here.
This is closer.
Which one's me?
Okay, okay.
Swap seats.
Get out of the car.
I'm driving.
You've lost your driving privileges.
Get out of the car, ma'am.
Ma'am?
Ma'am, am I getting kidnapped right now?
Where is he?
Where is he going?
No!
I was...
Oh my god, I thought I was part of a hidden run just then.
Alright, there we go.
Goodbye.
You've lost your driving privileges.
Don't worry, it still works.
Okay, like, I know this looks bad, but like, watch this.
I know this looks bad, but watch this.
Guys, I know this looks bad, but like, there we go.
See, it's that easy.
Guys, break the... break this.
Guys, break this.
Break this thing in front of me.
Guys, break the... guys, break the rails in front... guys, break the rail in front of me.
There we go.
We did it.
Oh my god, my car!
Okay, donate your car.
Somebody donate their car.
Give me your car.
Get out of the driver's seat right now.
This is GTA.
Get out of your driver's seat right now and give me your car.
Give me...
Thank you.
There we go.
We're gonna make it.
We're gonna make it this time.
Alright, this time we're gonna make it.
Alright, see?
It's that easy.
See?
We're almost there.
Guys, don't... guys, don't kill him before I... guys, stop.
Stop.
I have to be there.
Guys, guys, guys, I swear I have to be there.
Oh my god!
In the spirit of Fortnite, I have to be there for the kill!
Sorry, elimination.
Guys.
We need to be...
I need to be able to see it, guys.
I need to be able to see the content.
That's...
That's it.
Oh my god, this car is like one hit away.
Okay.
Alright!
Next destination!
Guys, next destination.
I have to be there, though!
I have to be there!
I swear to god.
Oh, I ran out of gas.
Give me your car.
Guy in front of me!
Stop!
I'm commandeering your car!
Guy in front of me!
Guys, I need a car.
You there!
Guys!
I need to commandeer a car!
Get over here!
Biker man!
Get off!
Biker man, get off!
Thank you.
Alright, there you go.
I swear.
Please!
Please let me out!
Okay.
Where did my bike go?
Where am I?
Okay.
Thank you.
Alright, don't worry.
We can make it.
We can make it before it's gone.
Alright.
Okay, but watch this sick trick, though.
Watch this.
Wow!
Look at that.
We can make it before it's gone.
We can definitely make it.
I ran out of gas.
Get off!
Give me your car!
Get out of the driver's seat right now!
And give me your car!
Get out!
Get out of the driver's seat right now and give me your car!
There you go.
Alright, we're here!
We're finally here!
We made it!
Let's go!
Woo!
We're here!
We're gonna fight him!
Let's go!
Let's fight him!
This is a robbery.
Let's go.
Let's summon him.
How do you summon him?
I've never got this far before.
Guys, in the spirit of Fortnite, how do we summon this guy?
I'd never expect to get this far.
I actually don't know.
No, no, you don't do this to me.
Don't.
I never got this far.
He's already...
There's no way.
Did you guys kill them?
Did you guys kill them already?
It's already...
Please, I need to see him!
Please, I don't want to...
I don't want to...
Get the content off, guys, please.
Oh my god.
What do you mean it's already dead?
What do you mean?
Who has a sword?
Drop a sword right now.
Drop a sword right now in front of me.
Who has it?
Does anyone have a sword?
Alright.
In the spirit.
You.
Give me your sword.
Give me a sword.
This is not a robbery.
Give me your sword right now.
You there.
Give me your sword or I'll take drastic measures.
No!
Where am I?
Where's the woman with the sword?
Where did she go?
They all look the same!
There's too many women!
Too many base form women!
Which one is the woman I'm looking for?
Oh, that was a cosmetic?
Oh.
Nevermind.
Alright.
In the spirit of Fortnite.
Let me go up here first before I say anything.
You must all kill each other except for me.
Except for me.
I'm safe.
I shall watch from up here.
Now fight.
Now fight everyone.
But not me!
Not me!
That's right.
You all fight each other.
Now Fortnite dance on his body.
Now Fortnite dance on his body right now.
This guy.
Fortnite dance.
It has to be the- No guys!
Guys!
On me!
It's you.
Now watch my child dance too.
That's fucking right.
Oh.
Now you die.
Wait, run him over.
Good.
Now I have two child.
Alright.
Now you all fight each other.
Entertain me.
Entertain me right now.
Oh wait, is that a- Oh my god, that's the- Am I allowed to be in this truck?
Am I- Am I allowed- Am I even allowed to be in this truck?
Like, yes.
Alright.
Sir, why are we in the storm, sir?
I demand blood, but not of me.
Two people behind me in this truck right now.
Punch each other.
Punch each other with your pickaxe right now.
Two people behind me in that truck.
I can't be reported.
I feel like that's the emperor
policy of the king says fight for my amusement right now.
The two people in the backseat punch each other.
Those two people in the backseat punch each other right now.
Did I see you shoot?
Did you just shot her?
You shot her, I saw it.
No shooting.
That's right.
Oh wait, wait, wait.
This is gonna be my first crown.
Wait, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
This is important.
Alright, nice.
Run her over.
Run somebody over.
Don't you be like them.
Run them over.
Oh wait, there's no more gas.
Oh, oh.
There's no more gas.
God damn it.
Can't believe it.
There's no more gas.
What would my child do?
Oh my god.
There's no gas anywhere.
Guys, give me a sec.
I need my spirit to start dancing.
Okay.
Dance.
Alright guys, let's dance.
Dance with my child.
Oh!
Okay, stop dancing with my child.
I'm gonna have to leave.
Alright, let's make a fight club.
Everybody, stop killing each other.
We're gonna make a fight club.
We're gonna make a punch club.
A copyright free fight club.
Alright, everybody.
Alright, come over here, everyone.
Come over here.
We have 23 seconds left.
Let me...
Oh, this is my last child use.
What happens to this child?
Oh, I can still... Okay.
Alright, everybody.
Stop shooting!
The emperor is speaking.
Thanks.
Okay.
Alright.
All of you, follow me.
We're gonna head to the next zone.
Everyone, follow me.
We're all gonna head to the next zone.
Stop fighting.
Stop.
Alright.
I'm gonna stand on this rock.
Everyone, stand in front of me.
Stand in a circle, everybody.
Stand in a circle.
I already have one.
Stand in a circle, everyone.
Guys, that's not a circle, guys.
Guys, this is not a circle.
This is not.
Look at that.
Zero crowns.
Alright, make a circle.
Make a circle, dragons.
Make a circle.
Alright, nice.
That's almost a circle.
Yes, that's half a circle.
Okay, alright.
That's a rhombus.
That's okay.
That's a really tight...
Now, take your gun out.
Find one person you wanna shoot at.
When I say...
When I shoot my gun, you shoot at that one person that you pick.
That one target you pick.
Alright?
When I shoot my gun, you shoot at them.
That one target you pick.
Guys...
Oh!
I had a silencer.
Sorry, that was an accident.
Sorry, I have to go to the other zone now.
I forgot I had a silencer.
Why did you run away?
Why did you run away, Flamingo?
Alright.
Alright, stand in a line.
Stand in a line, everybody.
Now that you're all assigned, stand in a line.
Okay, that's not a line.
Okay, guys.
Guys, do we need help with shapes, guys?
Okay.
You guys are gonna die to the zone.
Who's gonna be the first one to die to a zone?
Alright, guys.
Apparently, you guys can't figure out your shapes in time before we make it to the next zone.
Alright, single file!
Single file, everybody!
Single file!
Flamingo is first!
Single file, everyone!
Stand behind him!
You gotta move, Flamingo.
Alright, single file, everybody!
Single...
Follow this line.
Single file, guys!
Follow the...
Okay.
Okay, everyone.
Alright, class.
Okay, good job, class.
Just keep following...
Keep following the line.
Good job, everyone.
The conga line.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
This is a natural custom that I just happened to queue into.
Look at how cooperative everybody is in this random custom I...
Oh, guys.
I think we're dead.
Guys.
It might be over for us.
I think it's over for us.
No!
Everyone!
We can make it!
No!
We can make it, guys!
Just keep climbing!
Guys!
No, guys!
No fighting!
Think of the child!
Think of the...
My child!
He's running away!
No!
Oh!
He just dies!
Okay.
Okay, guys.
That's fine.
What are you trying to do?
What are you doing?
Yes!
That's right.
Who do you think you are?
Alright.
Alright, everybody.
I need a sacrifice.
Alright, default women.
You know what that means.
Oh!
You guys had swords this entire time?
No!
How did you win?
You weren't even part of the circle!
You weren't even...
Of course.
He wasn't even part of the circle!
Alright.
We'll do one last game.
I think my editor will be happy now.
The guy was here like...
Alright.
This is a real game now.
This is a real game.
We're gonna do...
We'll do duos.
He pulled the medkit strat.
It's a normal...
It's a custom...
But it's normal rules.
We're not fucking around anymore.
There's no more in the spirit of Fortnite anymore.
There's...
This is real gaming hours.
No more.
No more in the spirit of Fortnite.
Okay.
Okay, we can start.
Why can't I start the lobby?
Wait.
Who has the...
Okay, guys.
Somebody is queued up.
And you got...
If you see start match...
Press start match, guys.
If you...
If you are queued up right now...
And you see start match...
Start the match.
Guys.
Please.
You were the first one there.
Guys.
Start the match.
Please.
We need you to start the lobby.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
We're doing a new code.
Now, it's called sponsor.
Now.
Now, it's just sponsor.
Okay.
Custom key is...
I just deleted the E and the D.
Alright.
There we go.
Wait, I don't have it.
No, okay.
It's just me.
Wait, where did it go?
Wait, where is it?
Why can't I start the match?
Wait a minute.
Oh, no.
I lost control of the lobby.
Guys, I lost control of the lobby again.
Okay, I'm going to type.
Guys, I lost control.
Alright, guys.
New code.
I lost control of the lobby again.
Okay, maybe this will work.
Do I have it?
I have it.
Oh, my God.
I got my code back.
I got it.
Okay, it is editor.
Alright, guys.
Guys, this is a new...
I have control of the code.
This time, for real.
I have control of it.
This time.
He'll be fine.
It's like two and a half hours.
I think he'll be okay.
He should be okay.
Two and a half hours?
He should be fine.
Editor, edit this out.
Make it feel like I just happened to queue into...
You know, this is not custom lobby.
This is, you know...
This is just...
You know, a regular match.
Alright, here we go.
This is fine.
Alright, 177.
I forgot to start the match.
I almost forgot to start the match.
But we should be fine now.
Alright, last game.
Who's gonna be my duo?
Let's see.
Who's gonna be?
My duo hasn't loaded in yet.
Oh, this is a cute lobby, though.
This is a really cute lobby.
Oh my god.
Alright, fashion show.
Guys, fashion show time.
Fashion show, everybody.
Show me your drip.
Wait, that's so sick.
Oh, wait, isn't that...
Wait, this guy.
Wait.
He has a Samson skin.
He has a rare Samson.
He has a...
Oh my god.
Isn't that...
Isn't that super expensive?
Alright, you pick where to go, Finn.
Oh, whoops.
Okay, that's fine.
Mosaic that.
You pick.
Okay, I'll pick.
Wherever I go, it's gonna be a little bit...
chaotic.
Okay.
Mosaic that, editor.
I believe in you.
Oh, yeah.
You can do this, editor.
You got this.
Isn't that skin, like, super rare?
Guys, please.
Please let me live.
This is the last game.
Please.
You gotta let me live.
This is the last game.
Please don't do this to me.
Please.
You gotta let me live.
Give me your gun.
Oh my god.
Why are you stealing my gun?
Alright, guys.
Guys, this is a natural lobby.
Whoa, so natural.
So natural.
Wow!
In the spirit of Fortnite, these randoms that I just happened to queue up with just happened to let me go free.
That's crazy.
Holy shit.
You know what?
Maybe Fortnite's not so toxic after all, everybody.
Maybe...
Maybe people are nice in Fortnite.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
They won't know.
They won't know if they see a bush here.
Okay.
Please, I need to get the band-aid.
Please, you are on top of the band-aid that I need to get.
Whoops.
No, my bush.
My bush.
Guys.
In the spirit of Fortnite, Oh my god.
Oh, guys.
It's looking a little suspicious.
Sorry, I'm trying to get my band-aid.
Guys, it's looking a little suspicious that, you know, we gotta weed some people out.
So, like...
Alright, who wants to be part of my groupie?
Alright.
Show me your most expensive emote.
That's not copyrighted.
Okay, I obviously can't kill my teammate.
Alright.
This is my posse.
I'm gonna start a gang.
Wait, that's...
I'm gonna start a club.
Because, like, gangs are illegal.
But, like, I'm a very good person.
I'm gonna start a club.
It's gonna be called Club Doki.
Okay, guys.
Club, we love Fortnite.
Okay?
Because we love Fortnite.
And, like, we gotta say thank you to Fortnite for sponsoring.
Anyone have shields?
Guys, surely one of you guys have shields, right?
Surely one of you guys have shields, right?
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Alright.
Chug jug time.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we're fine.
Alright.
In the spirit of Fortnite, I gotta kill some of you guys.
So stand in front of me.
If you wanna be killed right now, stand right here.
Right where I ping.
Alright, and then, like, stand in the line after, okay?
Alright.
Wait, sorry, that's my gun.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
No!
Kill him!
Get me out!
Get the leader!
Finn!
Finn, where's Finn?
Stop!
Finn, I need you!
Finn!
Res me right now, Finn!
No!
Finn!
Wait, I need to report my teammate really fast.
I need...
Teammate got eliminated.
I need to report him.
He got...
No way!
In the spirit I need to report him.
What happened?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're still...
Still here!
They're still here!
Mr. President did not get down.
Okay!
Finn out there was doing a quadruple fucking flip instead of pressing E.
Now that's the spirit of Fortnite.
Oh my... I blame Finn.
This is Finn's fault.
Finn, show yourself in my chat right now.
Which one's Finn?
I won't ban you.
But like, show...
But like...
Oh, is this Jesus?
Oh my Jesus, no!
Which one is Finn?
Finn, hide!
I won't ban you, X.
Finn, I just wanna...
I wanna give you a special reward, Finn.
Anyone that... I don't know if you know this, Finn, but anyone that gets on my team gets...
gets a special prize.
Oh my god, is this like a... Oh wait, I really like this skin.
It's like a Toontown.
I'm Finn.
No, I'm Finn.
It's like those like, you know, like in the movies you're like, standing up and you committed this crime and then you're like, I did it.
No, I did it.
You can't ban us all.
You can't put all of us in.
We are Finn.
We are all Finn.
I'm Spiderman.
No, I'm Spiderman.
Wait, do you get fall damage?
Oh, you don't?
Wait, that's so broken.
How's there 47 people left?
Guys, it's killing time.
Sorry, it's elimination time.
Guys, it's... Shoot him.
Take the shot.
It's elimination time.
That's your teammate.
That's your...
Alright,
what's going on outside?
Look at all these gamers.
Wait, those aren't...
Take the shot.
That's right.
You're no longer friends when I'm watching.
Take the shot.
Dance on him.
That's fine.
It was worth it.
What do you mean?
Oh, wait.
Wait, I'm alive?
Who's still alive?
Oh, that guy's still alive.
We have...
Why do we keep fucking...
spectating Jesus?
Why?
Or is it Jesus?
I recently learned there's like the other pronunciation of Jesus and it's Jesus, right?
Is that how...
Is that how you say it?
Is that the real Finn?
Is that him?
Where is he?
It was never a Finn.
There was...
There was never a Finn in this lobby.
So he locked in.
Erased.
Oh my God!
Oh my God.
He just...
He got eliminated.
Aren't you not gonna save your friend?
Jesus?
What would Jesus do?
Okay, apparently leave his friend.
Goodbye,
killer.
Goodbye.
Would Jesus really let his friend die?
Sorry.
Get eliminated like that?
Is that truly what Jesus would do in Fortnite?
Would he let his friend get eliminated?
Jesus.
Save him.
Grab his car.
They don't know you're there.
They don't know.
Go back!
Go back and save your friend!
Where are you on the map?
Oh, we don't know where he is on the map.
I got...
He came back to finish the job.
Wait, where is your friend?
Could I be a Finn too?
Thank you, Mr. Chapman.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, where is your friend?
Where did he...
Where did he go?
You didn't res him, so...
I don't watch you no more.
I only watch homies.
You weren't a homie because you let him die.
Okay, editor.
Make sure you replace the die with eliminated.
Okay, wait, wait.
I'm gonna make another sound clip.
And then you take this audio...
And then replace the other audio of that moment.
I can't believe you let him get eliminated.
Okay, that should sync up.
Alright, and then you let him get eliminated.
Okay, you replace that...
With what I just said about dying.
What
is he...
What is he trying to do?
I demand more eliminations!
Jokey bird is hungry!
She is hungry!
She demands more eliminations!
Oh, shit!
It's desktop A3W18LV!
I need more blood!
That's right.
I demand more!
Oh, look at these nerds on high ground.
Okay, you guys wanna fight these nerds?
They're like right here.
That's where they are.
They're literally...
They're like right here.
Wait, is this...
Yeah, they're right here.
You wanna fight these nerds right here?
Okay, we got...
Alright, these guys...
They're right over here.
They're literally right here.
Look at these rats right here.
There's these rats here.
That's trying to bait people into the house.
They're like...
Look at this juicy loot we have.
We have here.
Wait, did he die?
Wait, did I...
Wait a minute.
Oh, no.
They're still alive.
Okay, I thought they got shot at.
I thought when I...
Alright, they're literally right here.
They have to move to zone in 22 seconds.
So you can literally...
Camp outside here.
And then just shoot them.
Shoot down on them.
Nevermind.
They're pussies.
Alright.
Let's see where these guys are going.
Wait, what?
Who are they shooting at?
Oh, there's a fight in front of them.
Yes!
Fight!
Give me more eliminations!
I demand more eliminations!
That's right!
Oh my god, there's a porta potty.
Doki is hungry!
Feed me!
I require...
Blood right now.
Where is the guy that they're chasing?
Oh, right here.
Oh my god, carry him!
Carry him!
Oh, she's dead.
Carry her!
Do a fortnite dance in front of her!
Do a fortnite dance in front of this girl!
Go back in the zone right now!
And do a fortnite dance!
I'm so tired.
Oh no.
Wait, why are you guys fighting in zone?
Oh, because he has the...
Oh, that's so smart.
You let your homie die like that though?
Oh my god!
No wonder he has that skin.
No fucking wonder.
That's actually crazy.
Alright, who's still alive?
Alright.
Yeah, no shit.
He's a gamer.
Oh, they're in the...
Oh my god!
Nevermind, anime was not on her side.
Oh my god, anime...
Don't worry!
It'll be different for him, right?
Okay, nevermind.
Guys, I think I learned that you're not supposed to bring a sword to a gunfight.
I...
I think I figured that out.
I think I realized that...
A sword...
A sword in a gunfight is not...
It's not it.
But how did Ice Spice do it?
How did Ice Spice 1v4 this?
Who would've thought?
That's crazy.
Oh shit!
Wait, Jesus is still alive!
No, he got the sword.
He got the sword, guys.
Oh my god, it's over!
He got the sword!
Curse.
It's a curse.
Every time you get the sword...
Bro, I wonder...
Imagine if he just got shot right there.
Oh my god, what's he gonna do?
Make the child dance for me.
I told you it's the curse of the sword.
It's the curse of the sword!
I told you!
Anybody that has the sword...
They perish!
Carry him and then...
Emo on his body.
Dance.
Dance for him.
Come on.
Come on, dance for him.
He's like...
No!
No, editor!
Edit this out!
Edit this out, editor!
Don't put this in!
Oh my god!
It was a distraction!
How do you feel, buddy?
And then he's just gonna have trauma...
PTSD after that.
Oh my god.
He survived.
He's gonna have fucking trauma after that.
Bro, it was a honeypot.
It was a honeypot mission all along.
He took the shots for the team.
In more ways than one.
Now let the children dance.
Let the children dance.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's eight squads left.
Four more teams.
Wait, who's still alive?
Me, I'm still alive.
And then there's...
Oh, the bush people.
Guys, you wanna know where the bush men are?
Where is this?
Nevermind.
I guess they ran off.
Oh my god, he got a car.
Wait, he had a car?
He like parked a car there?
Run him over!
You know you want...
Aw, coward!
Cowards!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, they're gaming.
There's no... they're fucking gaming.
They're freaking gaming right now.
Oh, nevermind, he's dead.
Unless...
He's jumping?
Child dance.
Gamer moment right there.
Wait, how did the flamingo live?
Goodbye, child.
No!
He ran away!
The child ran away!
He like booked it!
He actually...
He just booked it!
Alright, who's still alive?
Who the heck is this guy?
Who is... he has no...
Oh, there you go.
Pokecraft.
Oh, he's a solo.
Hello!
That's me!
Someone do a drive-by and shoot him.
Oh my god, he did do a drive-by!
Was that worth it?
Hello!
Goodbye!
I don't think that was worth it.
What did I do?
What do you mean?
Oh my god, the flamingo.
Goodbye, flamingo.
Wait, what?
Oh, is it 1v1?
Oh my god, it's a 1v1v1!
It's a 1v1v1!
It's a 1v1!
Oh my god, he did it for him!
He did it for him!
Oh my god!
They did it!
He did it for that guy!
The honeypot to victory!
The backshots for the win!
It was all for him!
Oh my god, that was so fun!
That was so fun!
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you!
I can't believe this is a sponsored stream.
Honestly, I had so much fun today.
Honestly, the whole day was incredibly fun.
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you!
That was fun!
Yeah, it was!
Thank you all for playing with me!
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you again to Fortnite and Epic for sponsoring the video.
He offended me!
Hashtag Flamingos!
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you!
Huge shoutout again to Fortnite and the Epic Games for sponsoring me.
We're going to have a video highlight.
I'm actually curious on how this is going to look.
There might be like, you know, off-stream content in there depending on how it's...
on what we need and what we need that I didn't provide from the stream.
But, I had a great time.
It's actually crazy to be sponsored to play a game that I really enjoy.
And if you guys didn't know, I have a creator code so you guys can support me via other means.
If you like buying Fortnite cosmetics, this helps a lot.
It just basically gives me a percentage of some of the...
So like, instead of it going all the way to Epic, it actually goes...
A percentage of that goes to me.
So yeah, this is like...
It's just Doki Bird.
But yes, it was incredibly fun.
Thank you everybody for coming today.
Thank you everybody for watching this morning with Minecraft.
And for watching today for the Fortnite sponsor.
It really does mean a lot, everyone.
I'm going to go head off now, guys.
But thank you all for watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
It was great seeing all the new changes.
And the guns being hitscan is so cool because I'm really bad at projectile.
So I love the hitscan update.
Cause like, I can only use hitscan guns.
I don't know why.
My mind is not wired to figure out how projectiles work.
So like, for me, it's really fun to be able to shoot hitscan guns.
Because like, it's like my best, my strongest strength in shooting games.
So yeah, and I loved all the new cosmetics and the outfits that they have in the newest map with the newest island.
With the different locations they added.
And the boss fights.
And the cosmetics and everything.
So thank you again.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!